round-the-clock rescue and recovery
efforts at the site of that collapsed
apartment building in surfside florida
just north of miami beach overnight
crews continued to search through the
rubble in hopes of finding survivors
at least four people are confirmed dead
and more than 150 are unaccounted for
a little more than two days after the
condominium tower came
crashing down no one has been found in
the rubble since yesterday morning
as florida governor ron desantis is
calling for a timely
explanation for how this could have
happened the hours are growing desperate
for the hundreds of rescuers
still on the scene mark strassman is in
surfside with the latest on the rescue
efforts and the possible warning signs
this building may have been
in danger of collapsing mark good
morning
hey good morning dana officially this is
still a search and rescue operation
but with each hour that goes by and
these
search teams find no sign of any more
survivors
it is a grim reality check for everybody
involved not just the search teams but
of course the anxious families who are
desperately waiting for
some sort of sign that their loved ones
are okay but the bombshell
overnight was a release of a engineering
study
that showed that a couple of years ago
there were already signs that this
building
had clear engineering structural worries
with high-tech tools like cameras and
listening devices
along with brute strength and bucket
brigades urban search and rescue teams
looked
for any survivors from early thursday
morning's tower collapse
55 apartment units pancaked as people
inside them slept
now time may be running out all of our
training tells us that for at least
the first 72 hours there are high
likelihood
of people that could be alive in there
crews battle fire
rain exhaustion and even the threat of
another disaster
the building you see behind me is also
in danger
of potential collapse while rescuers
face those risks
family members of the missing face
uncertainty
i think i'm trying to brace myself for
the worst
and the best and it's really hard
just not knowing it's just the worst
person sergio lozano
is looking for his parents i was on the
phone with her
at 1 30. she called me up and she said i
think there's an earthquake
and she looked down the balcony and the
pool area
had kind of a sinkhole
and then the building started to shake
it rattled she and she screamed and then
the phone went
dead forensic inspectors wonder whether
something failed
underneath the building to support its
weight the tower's builders
had to drive concrete pilings deep into
the sandbar
one coastal threat salt water intrusion
it can seep into the concrete corrode
the steel inside the pilings
and worst case shift the base of a
building
after the calamity officials reportedly
saw a hole
opening up under the garage they will
try to see where the source of the where
the water is coming from and did that
penetrate in the columns and foundations
as a 40 year old building champlain
south's condo association is required by
county law
to reinspect from the ground up an
engineer's report from 2018 obtained by
cbs news
found abundant cracking in concrete
columns
beams and walls in the parking garage
and
major structural damage to a concrete
structural slab
caused by failed waterproofing that if
not repaired in a timely fashion
would cause the concrete to deteriorate
exponentially
donna berger is an attorney representing
the condo board
from the engineers that i've been
speaking to they believe it's probably a
sub-surface
issue what that means is what was the
infrastructure on which this building
was built
that 2018 engineering report
specifically warned of structural issues
not only in the parking garage but also
under the pool deck and under the
entrance drive
they were just about to get started
working on some of those issues
when the building collapsed two and a
half years later
for cbs this morning saturday mark
strassman surfside florida
lots of big questions as these families
continue to wait this agonizing
wakes heartbreaking watching them truly
is